a producer gave you some advice that was
pretty lasting
yeah so um i i was a personal trainer at
the time
and i was still you know i was doing
short films and and and all of that
stuff i think i was
making my first feature which was a back
alley
you know group of friends putting their
credit cards
you know into the pot and just making a
making a film i think i was doing that
at the time
and i was he was somebody who was very
integral
developing the fast and furious
franchise as well as the
the show 24. and uh
he just happened to be one of my clients
and and
we you know became friends uh
from the whole thing and he was gave me
some great advice
and one of the things he he told me was
number one he said don't be
a a-hole that was one of the biggest
rules so this business is so small
that if you're a jerk it's going to come
back around
so that was one of the first things he
told me he's like
and he was very colorful in the way he
explained it but he's like that
pa that you're working with on set one
week
a year later they might be producing the
show that you're working on
you know it's that that's the way this
business works so if you're a jerk to
that extra
they might be the star of some show in a
year or two so you just never you know
you should never treat people you know
poorly and
especially i mean that's just in life
but especially in this business because
it is really so small you're end up
going to have to work with the same
people again
most likely and the other thing he told
me was if i really wanted to pursue
being a
creator a storyteller a
filmmaker to never be a you know no job
is too small never
be afraid of of being the coffee runner
or being the
in charge of extras or whatever it is
and also to diversify
so the business was changing so much at
that time it was when
uh digital was just coming out it was
kind of taking over everything
um and uh
even dvds and that whole blu-ray
everything that was
the industry was just shifting and
shifting and shifting so he told me to
diversify or die those were his exact
words
if you want to make it and survive in
this business diversify or die
and i took that to heart and that's why
if you look up my credits you'll see
i've done so many different jobs is
because
i basically adopted the attitude of
just not turning down a job so if i was
offered a job
and i had the ability to do it and i had
the
time to do it that i would do it and and
again
it goes back to that viewing it as
an education he's like oh i'm going to
learn about this and he also told me
that same thing of
look if you learn what it is to be a
grip
and if you learn what what it takes to
be the the
you know art department if you learn
those things it's going to make you a
better director
because you'll understand what it takes
to do those jobs
and you'll understand what they're going
through to do those jobs in the same
perspective
it's very important for a director to be
understand acting
because you'll then be able to
understand the process
or understand that there is a process
with actors and be able to sympathize
with them or
help enable them tell their truth in
that role
same thing with uh editing as a director
i think it's so important to understand
editing because you understand what
you're shooting
there are directors who are not editors
but i think you need to have a certain
understanding of that in order to be
effective it helps you with time
management on set it helps you when you
know you have your scene
you know you don't need to shoot four
more angles that you'll never use and be
on the cutting room floor because
you know you have the scene it's there
you've got all the pieces you need
um so those two things i already knew
were important to be a director but i
didn't think about
the other stuff the the what is the
gaffer doing what is the
grips doing what are the makeup and hair
and you know kind of
learning all those different departments
it's only going to help you become a
better director
is what he told me and and so i took
that to heart and i took every job i
could take
i did everything i could do and and just
felt like it was a
an education for me um and and would
just help me be
better at the job that i was trying to
pursue do you ever feel guilty turning
down work
um you mean now yeah my sense is that
you're
eager and you love what you do that if
if an opportunity comes up you almost
feel bad if you can't take it because
maybe
totally committed to something else yes
yes yeah
for sure and uh what's interesting
uh and and topical right now is that i
had to
back out of directing a film uh overseas
because of the pandemic
and actually i was over there when it
started getting really bad
i was over there prepping and it's going
to be
a fantastic film i am uh now kind of
jealous that i
didn't get to direct it but um
when this whole thing first came up i
started getting bad and
and uh was definitely really worried
about
getting home because it became one of
those things of
uh you know at the time they're like you
know what you could just stay a couple
extra weeks and wait it out
and then when it's safe to travel again
you know it was one of those and
but what what ended up happening was the
international flight started cancelling
like just stopping all international
flights
and i went oof i think i'm going to have
to go home
because i can't get stuck here i've got
a family and all that
so i did i ended up getting home
uh and uh um
the last weekend where those
international flights were flying
i got home and uh did the quarantine did
all that stuff got tested and i was fine
but uh the
it the whole thing got pushed because of
it and but then it came down to this
thing
when they wanted to shoot it still was
just not a safe time to be to go and
travel and
and the worry of being able to get home
was so
uh you know
just too big of a worry it was just too
much to be able to commit
and go there and do it and i felt
horrible turning that down because i had
committed to
doing this project with with these
wonderful filmmakers
and some of which i had really dreamed
about working with for a long time
because they were a big part of asian
cinema like with with
uh you know jetley and jackie chan and
all that and so
i had to turn it down i felt so so bad
um but obviously it's not under my
control
it was out of my control the whole
situation so
but yeah i think i do feel that way
because
um i just enjoy i
enjoy creating and helping tell stories
in whatever the capacity whether it's
you know even if it's stunt coordinating
that's still your part of telling that
story you're part of telling the
the story of the action of how it's
happening and unfolding and
i just love i love that process so
um
and i think there's also that element of
feeling like you might be able to help
somebody
and then not being able to you know
having to say no i can't help you
because i get those those uh calls
uh you know fairly often it's it's
somebody
usually when they're calling me because
they need your piece of expertise or
something
uh that you know you might be able to
be that puzzle piece for them and then
when you're not available
uh obviously that's that sucks but i
always try and
recommend somebody i'm like wait call
this person or i'm definitely that
that way as well i really love to to if
i can't do it get
somebody else the work you know what i
mean
and so i do that
you